how do I find somebody to model one of
my favorite strategies in business and
the one that saved my company from from
bankruptcy from total failure is
modeling success so it's fine somebody
who's already done what you're trying to
do and put their strategies to work
because if you try to come up with every
single idea yourself you're going to
fail because you're not great at
everything you can learn and leverage
from the things that have worked for
other entrepreneurs put your twist on it
and make it work for you they're proven
strategies that work and you can make
them work for you too I got a question
from one of my readers Ruth and she
wrote in to say how do you go out and
find a successful person to model when
there's nobody doing what I do how do
you find the team what fate so she's an
artist what famous person is selling
online painting courses so here's the
thing ok if you are an entrepreneur you
should be doing something that is
different right if you're doing the same
thing that everybody else is doing
you're not going to have success you
have to be different that's part of
being a successful entrepreneur I face
the exact same problem when I was
starting my first business ok it was a
biotechnology software company and
modeling saved it but when I was first
trying to figure out how do I model I
had the same problem there was no huge
successful biotechnology software
company so Who am I going to model
there's nobody doing exactly how we did
it so Who am I going to model and that
was frustrating and I had to then
realize when I expanded my search when
expanded my parameters I was able to
find companies that I could successfully
model so instead of just sticking to
biotechnology software which was super
limited i expanded it to software
companies and I looked at mcafee
Microsoft and into it and lived how they
got started and looked at their stories
and even though they sold business
software and accounting software and
productivity software had nothing to do
with biotechnology software wasn't
related but it was still software
and I looked at those strategies I
looked at how Bill Gates started his
business not how he makes an extra
million now but how did he start how did
he go from his idea to his first million
dollars that's what I wanted to do
that's what I wanted to replicate that's
what I needed the copy that's what I
wanted to model even though he was not
in my specific field so if you're
looking at selling painting courses
online maybe nobody's had a lot of
success doing it that's fine but tons of
people have had success selling online
courses and tons of people have success
as painters look at what they've done
their strategies their secrets what's
helped them become successful can still
apply to you even though nobody's done
exactly what you're doing it's a
limiting belief that there's nobody out
there to model and that makes it
difficult to go out and do and I don't
want that to hold you back it almost
held me back and I was frustrated nobody
had been hugely successful in my
industry there was no no model to copy
but instead of giving up just by simply
expanding my search and finding those
companies software companies that were
non biotech that helped me get beyond
the other thing that's really helped me
in modeling is pick people who you are
passionate about excited about people
who inspire you who have nothing to do
with your business at all you just love
them there's something about them that
you really like so one of the people who
I really look up to it and enjoy
watching his stuff and learning from him
and steve jobs and how he marks in how
he brands and how he's create some great
products I don't sell computers I don't
sell phones I don't sell any of the
stuff that Apple sells but there's a lot
that you can learn as an entrepreneur in
marketing and branding from him and the
more you look up to and respect that
person the more likely you're going to
actually follow what they did and
actually execute and follow through even
know people may have nothing to do with
painting or even anything to do online
there are people who you look up to in
the entrepreneurial world then you can
still learn from their success and apply
it to your business if you can combine
those two if you can combine
industry-specific
so either people selling courses online
or painters combine that with other
aspiration entrepreneurs who look up to
and what's led to their success you have
a whole wealth of knowledge to pull from
to model from to help you grow your
business belief if you guys watching
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below I love seeing us come in and
please leave a comment underneath they
make my day they make me want to do more
of this for you and you've a comment
leave it below a question below I'll
make a video response thank you so much
and I'll see you soon